okay so the evidence is overwhelmingly
conclusive there was absolutely a
massive global Cataclysm that happened
approximately 12,000 980 years ago that
was a total reset button for human
civilization in this video I'm going to
show you five key pieces of evidence
including core I sample data taken from
both Antarctica and Greenland so data
taken from the Younger Dryas black matte
layer the unexplainable extinction event
of 75% of all mammals in North America
and 120 large megafauna ie mammals
larger than 100 pounds that all went
extinct at the same period of time
evidence of the sudden and unexplainable
end of the last ice age including a
massive 400 foot rise in sea level that
happened in a very short period of time
as well as a key piece of evidence that
proves that there was an advanced human
civilization dating back more than
13,000 years yet despite the
overwhelming evidence taken from the
most recent and technologically advanced
scientific analysis ever taken on this
subject it's still not being taught in
schools it's still not printed in the
textbooks and you still won't hear about
it from almost anyone in mainstream
science now let's start with key
evidence from the core ice samples taken
from Antarctica and Greenland both these
samples confirm that there was two
events one that happened twelve thousand
nine hundred eighty years ago give or
take five years as well as another one
that happened 1,400 years later or
eleven thousand six hundred years ago
where we saw a few things happen on
planet Earth in a very short period of
time including a 400-foot rise in sea
level which happened so rapidly that
there's evidence that suggests that it
may have raised as much as 30 feet
globally in just a 24-hour period as
well as a 15 degree fahrenheit
temperature swing that went from one end
of the spectrum to the other in that
period of time most of which happen in
just a few cycles of seasons ie a couple
years you know it's interesting with all
this talk about global warming right now
everyone's fussing over what the effects
will be of a 3 degree fahrenheit
temperature increase guys we're talking
about 5 to 6 times as much as that now
the process for getting this data from
the kurai samples is very interesting
you can literally see and measure the
rise and fall of sea levels from one
year to the next so you're probably
asking what could
cause such an event well the evidence is
overwhelming that there was a cosmic
collision ie a comment or an asteroid
hit the North American ice shelf which
at that time was more than 2 kilometers
thick on average that's more than a mile
thick guys in some places more than 2
miles thick this cosmic impact would
have caused a massive evaporation of a
significant portion of the North
American ice shelf not all of it but
enough of it to cause massive flooding
as well as having a significant portion
of this ice blasted into the atmosphere
only to be rained down in significant
proportions around the globe for days
and weeks to come now further evidence
that supports this cosmic impact
includes the Younger Dryas black mat
boundary that you can see in these
pictures here and there have been
samples taken from dozens of locations
across three continents around the world
that shows that more than 50 million
kilometers almost a third of the Earth's
landmass was literally covered in 2 to 3
inches of nano diamonds melt glass
iridium even extraterrestrial helium now
these elements are only found from two
causes nuclear blasts and cosmic
collisions however when you take into
account the extra-terrestrial helium as
it's called it's pretty conclusive that
it was in fact a cosmic collision now at
that same exact period of time as we're
seeing in the soil samples there is an
unexplainable mass die-off like I said
75% of all mammals in North America went
extinct in a very short period of time
as well as 120 mega fauna or bambbles
that are larger than 100 pounds many of
which let me look at these pictures some
of these you have never ever seen before
you never knew bee existed they're not
covered in the textbooks largely however
the current explanation by modern
science is that well apparently humans
must have caused the mass extinction
that a bunch of primitive hunters and
gatherers over killed and over hunted
and that's why there was this mass
die-off
however this evidence that contradicts
that for example there has been mass
mortality sites of woolly mammoths they
have found fields of more than 1,000
will be mammoths many of which had
broken legs as if their body had been
blasted over with their legs still
standing and some of which still have
food in their mouths this further
validates that there was a sudden and
cosmic collision that caused a mass
extinction event for so many animals in
a short period of time
so if this was possible for the
dinosaurs why wouldn't we think that
it's possible to have happened to humans
which we know were alive at that time
take for example gobekli tepe now most
people aren't aware of this it's located
in Turkey not far from Mesopotamia and
it is dated at least to the eleven
thousand six hundred years ago through
analyzation of organic matter pottery
and other elements and artifacts found
at that site eleven thousand six hundred
years ago now this site is more than
7,000 years older than Stonehenge which
is largely mysterious in of itself right
not only is it seven thousand years
older it's more than 50 times bigger as
verified through ground-penetrating
radar and only five percent of it has
been excavated
now what's particularly interesting
about this site isn't just the fact that
it's the world's oldest and largest
megalithic structure but the fact that
it's the first building or structure to
ever align perfectly
north and south not just in the
direction of north and south but perfect
now first of all that's obviously not an
accident when you consider just how
incredible this site is that there's 20
to 50 ton pillars that clearly have a
celestial meaning to them however one of
the key pieces of information about
gobekli tepe
is that you could not possibly construct
a perfectly north south facing structure
without having advanced astronomical
knowledge so how were they able to have
that 11,000 600 years ago after all
according to our textbooks the Sumerians
that date back 7,000 years ago are the
ones that started all of human
civilization yet this exceeds that by
thousands of years and it's completely
unexplainable and by the way they also
have evidence at the site of advanced
agriculture that took place at that time
and like I said advanced agriculture
wasn't supposed to have started until
the Sumerians more than 5,000 years
later that's interesting now here's a
key piece of information you need to
take into consideration right now as of
today approximately 40% of the entire
world's population lives right on the
coast and more than 75% of the world's
population lives within sixty kilometers
of a coast and then when you take into
consideration the evidence that show
that there was a 400 foot rise in sea
level New York Washington DC Los Angeles
Tokyo Beijing
Londyn so many other I mean I have to
stop there because I could keep ending
them how many of the world's most
advanced civilizations are right on the
coast and what would happen if the sea
levels rose as much as 30 feet overnight
now that being said this event once have
made the entire human race go extinct
there would of course been survivors and
that's where gobekli tepe comes in it
suggests that this that humanity was
trying to rebuild itself after this
massive Cataclysm and that it shows that
11,000 600 years ago was when miss sight
essentially was stopped operating was
buried and at that same exact period of
time there was another event that caused
a massive rise and fall of global sea
levels temperatures as well as a
significant number of animals going
extinct all at that same period of time
I don't think that's a coincidence
but many people arguing okay if there
was an advanced civilization where's all
the evidence where's the metal buildings
where's the fiber-optic cables
underground where is all this stuff
we're talking over 10,000 years ago I
mean take into consideration what
happens if you leave a car outside for
just a few decades starts eating itself
away or even houses for example if you
don't do a significant restoration
project on a house after a few decades
the house will fall in on itself now
let's compare the Titanic as an example
more than 50 thousand tons of steel and
iron has been underwater for just more
than a hundred years and it's nearly all
the way gone and in another hundred
years it will almost be non-existent now
think about what would happen over
10,000 years the only thing that you
would have left is stone
now something else that we find across
the world across more than six
continents in more than 500 cultures is
the story of a flood well look at these
photos now these are from Joe Rogan
podcast with Randall Carlson and Graham
Hancock but what you're seeing here is
photos from Montana Idaho in Washington
they showed these absolutely massive
ripples more than 50 feet tall and
hundreds of feet long and absolutely
proved and show that there was some sort
of massive flood that happened in fact
take a look at this photo it compares
this location in Montana with Niagara
Falls now in Niagara Falls approximately
150,000 to 200,000 cubic feet of water
spill over the falls
every second however when you compare
this size it shows that this would have
been more than 350 million cubic feet of
water per second take for example
kaho which is located between California
and Nevada this Lake is 22 miles long 12
miles wide and up to 1600 feet deep and
there's enough water in this lake to
cover the entire state of California in
fourteen and a half inches of water now
consider what would happen if you
instantly evaporated or melted a just a
portion of the North American Ice Shelf
like I mentioned earlier was more than
two kilometers thick on average once
that explaning massive rise in sea level
at that time we know that at the time of
the last ice age the sea level was 400
feet lower than it is today so this
explains a lot of megalithic structures
that have been found off the coast of
various regions around the world so when
you connect the dots in these key pieces
of evidence including the ice core
samples the Younger Dryas boundary soil
samples the mass extinction the rapid
ending of the last ice age the sudden
rise of temperatures and the global sea
levels and gobekli tepe which is
completely unexplainable anyways guys
I'm going to close up there leave a
comment let me know your thoughts and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and help me
spread the message take care everybody